il n'y a pas grand chose à faire pour
ceux qui sont coincés à Goris sinon
d'attendre que le temps passe
ne s'occuper comme on peut pour ne pas
devenir fou disent d'être Lana et
surtout ne pas perdre l'espoir
mais chaque fois qu'elle parle de la
maison c'est comme un coup de poing dans
le ventre
sa maison son mari qui l'attend seul et
malade depuis deux mois
ces équipes lui rapportent les documents
en temps réel de graves pénuries de
nourritures des pénuries de médicaments
si bien que le gouvernement a du imposé
un système de rationnement pour éviter
la catastrophe
du monde depuis que ces manifestants de
l'Azerbaïdjan qui prétendent d'être des
écologistes ont érigé des barricades
plus rien n'y passe ni marchandise ni
humain
[Musique]
Diana 28 ans qui était à ereva en
Arménie quand le blocus a commencé au
mois de décembre elle habite depuis dans
cet hôtel de Goris avec des dizaines
d'autres familles qui s'inquiète sort de
leur proches car même communiquer avec
eux relèvent du hasard ou de la chance
les coupures de courant et d'Internet
par l'Azerbaïjan son quotidienne à cité
panacare la capitale les joindres ne
serait-ce que quelques minutes est un
des rares moments de grâce pour ses
enfants séparer de leur père et de leurs
cousins qui tentent de les rassurer à
distance ce qui est Macron c'est
vraiment le côté chronique de ce blocus
et on ne sait pas combien de temps ça
peut durer anaïs est originaire du au
Canada et psychologue bénévoles forcée
de constater que rien ne malgré les
demandes de Bruxelles et de Washington
laserbaïdjan refuse de lever le blocus
et profite des besoins de gaz de
l'Europe pour avancer ses pions sans
aucune conséquence
avant la frontière de l'Azerbaïdjan
de son balcon il se demande furieuse
attendent pour mettre fin au blocus car
ce sont eux qui étaient censés maintenir
l'ordre sous l'égide d'une mission de la
paix
déployée au terme de la guerre sanglante
de 2020 entre l'Azerbaïdjan et le Karaba
soutenu par les forces arméniennes on
les voit les Russes partout mais ils ne
font rien dit-elle c'est tout comme si
la Russie regardait ailleurs préoccupée
par sa guerre en Ukraine
son neveu est un des milliers de soldats
Arméniens morts au combat il y a deux
ans et elle craint que la guerre
reprenne et avance
finlandais et membre d'une mission
d'observation du Conseil européen qui
vient tout juste de débarquer à Goris
pour analyser la situation la frontière
mais tous regardent eux aussi impuissant
la crise humanitaire qui se dessine
derrière ses montagnes dans le haut
Karaba
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra pour que la
communauté internationale les entend